uh the start of today but uh he's  suddenly in trouble ah nobody's safe  almost and okay hang on second  what's happening ivanka the queen  attacking one black rook the other  oh wow  oh no  a huge blunder by eric hansen heartbreak  for eric hansen he got his queen trapped  look at this the black knight covers any  escape square for the white queen and  the black knight also defends both the  black rooks  turn around  you saw it first ivanka it took me a  while because it's not obvious eric  missed it and there we go i think we're  about to see a result because the white  queen loses herself for just a rook  black will emerge a whole rook up  heartbreak for the canadian i think eric  hansen just let his clock run out look  at that he was so close  to winning against a super strong player  young christoph duda a blunder in time  trouble i think he had two seconds left  on the clock when he made that movement  look at young christophe duda as well he  knows he got super lucky